there's a rumor that's been going on the
internet that you're going to be that
you could be
or already have been told that you would
be the next james bond
now that's crazy rumor it was going all
over the place
get excited yeah uh
first of all there's like an internet
thing yeah it was an internet thing
here's the deal with the internet
you got to take these things with a
grain of salt i mean i had a guy come up
to me the other day and said according
to the internet
yeah i'm 45.
that can't be true there's no way you're
45. no
no i'll give you a better example like a
year ago
please yes
about a year ago i showed up to uh to
work
and the hair and makeup people were like
congratulations and i said what happened
they said you're the lone ranger i said
what are you talking about there was a
rumor that you were going to be the lone
rangers it is all over the internet
you know and it's supercool.com and uh
you know we love
television.com it's right there elephant
lone ranger
and i was like this is fantastic you
know
this is the lone rain they were like tim
we need you on the set and i was like
you
[Laughter]
oh ranger
tell the crew to take a half an hour
okay
alone [ __ ] rain
i don't know if you uh if you saw the
movie yeah yeah you dodged a bullet i
wasn't in it
so uh but uh come on
i would have taken it i would happily
take it but i'll tell you uh that being
said
uh i feel like this one might be true
you think you
you could james bond well tell me what
your james bond would be like you got to
put your spin on it let's see
i think that's important everybody
brings a little something to it uh
first of all i'm not sure the accent is
necessary
why not he's british he's he's double
seven he's madness her majesty's secret
service gotta keep it fresh
okay maybe he was he was born there but
then his parents split and you know he
spent most of his
years in like seattle
[Laughter]
now he's back i like this idea so your
bond maybe uh speaks with a it's kind of
american
i mean i could do an accent if it was
necessary i mean i don't want to
use the job right here i mean still
cordoy what's the matter with ringo
well i'll tell you something else you
just lost the job
you so aren't getting this job now this
is not an audition
yeah trust me this is now your audition
reel throw it in my mind
oh we saw him on conan check this out
it's mad with ringo
i think the key though is he's got to be
a little more chill you know a little
more like
he just needs to take it you know like
i think he should smoke weed james bond
should smoke weed
the last guy drank like heinekens yeah i
mean it used to be like martinis and a
bow tie and now he's drinking beers and
i think the natural progression is
you know you know bond
james bond
[Applause]